It's a story of poor public policy
and complacency going back decades.
It's a story of the
inability of the Indian state
to show up when the Indian
people need it the most.
On Saturday, India saw the
worlds highest ever case tally
of over 400,000 infections.
Are we likely to see a peak soon
or are things likely to get
worse before they get better?
I don't think from the
very beginning we've ever
had an accurate picture
of the virus in India
and we certainly don't have
an accurate picture now.
This really was the first
tragedy that I've ever seen
that's played out so close to
me on my social media feeds.
People in their own
close networks of family
and friends crying out for help
on their social media feeds.
I mean, it can't get any closer than this.
India is no stranger to pandemics
but modern India has escaped some
of the worst pandemics the world has seen.
For example, the previous version of SARS,
India pretty much escaped that.
So it's fair to say that India
didn't really have any competence to deal
with global pandemics of this sort.
India was one of the first
countries to actually
impose a very, very strict
nationwide lockdown.
I remember Prime Minister Modi came
on television at prime time
and said, within four hours
the country will be locked
down effectively from midnight.
The urgency behind the
lockdown left many people
with a lack of preparation.
India has a massive internal migration,
waves of people really
flow from the villages.
So suddenly when factories
were ordered to be shut,
millions of people were
rendered unemployed,
virtually overnight.
Then we could see waves
of these internal migrants
on roads trudging back to
their villages on foot.
There were extremely sad
and grim instances where
they were so tired that
they chose to sleep
and they were down by trains and buses.
The predictions were for the
worst sort of carnage in India.
However, as the
pandemic kind of ran
through the population,
India's mortality rate ended
up being among the lowest in the world.
Everyone around could see people affected
by the coronavirus, even
if they went to hospital,
they would get out of hospital
relatively soon and relatively healthy
and here we are even talking
about people age 70
plus, 75, 80 and older.
Yeah, I mean, there was a lot of theories
whether India reached a
level of herd immunity
at that point.
They were other theories going around,
like India is a warm country,
whether south Asian populations
were more genetically immune
or disposed to not feel the
worst effects of COVID, but none
of them were particularly well-proven
but the official numbers
were kind of showing
that there was something going on anyway.
You saw Modi at the World
Economic Forum saying
that India had basically
contained the virus
and had saved the world from corona.
The Central Bank itself, the
reserve bank of India came out,
with a really quite jubilant statement
in January saying that the
country had bent the virus
curve like Beckham, which
was obviously a very
odd statements come
out for a Central Bank
but that was the kind of
atmosphere at the time.
You had cinemas opening, you had, you know
the wedding season started and
you had these mass weddings
these huge, beautiful Indian
weddings with, you know
hundreds and hundreds of people.
And all of this was done without that very
clear public health
messaging that you need
when you're in the middle of a pandemic.
It was almost like India
was an exceptional country
that didn't succumb
to a pandemic that was
affecting the rest of the world.
What became clear very quickly
was what we had suspected
all along,
and what many epidemiologists
have been telling us
which is that India had
been severely under-counting
both its infections and its deaths.
We know that many, many, many deaths
in normal times in India
aren't properly recorded
particularly when you
get into the hinterland
which is where 70% of
India's population live.
Something like only 20 to 30%
of deaths are properly recorded.
So the government engaged in a lot
of grandstanding about
how fabulously it had done
and yet what happened, turned
out very differently indeed.
This really has been the
first major global crisis
that's played out since
social media became such
a huge factor in people's lives
and particularly in India,
social media has caught on
in the last few years,
there are half a billion
WhatsApp users.
But what happened was
real crowdsourced chaos
that was playing out on social media.
There was misinformation
about fake Covid cures,
immunity boosters, herbal
concoctions that could save people
from getting Covid.
Dab some lemon juice on your
nostril, and you'll be safe.
The problem is that a lot
of people that use
social media have gotten
onto the internet very, very recently.
So it's really difficult
for them to distinguish
what's fake and what's real.
Facebook said it had removed 12
million pieces of misinformation relating
to COVID globally, you
know, from it's network.
But you know, that's really a drop
in the ocean considering how many millions
of misinformation pieces
are still floating
around cyberspace.
So a lot of that
misinformation has actually
come back to haunt a lot of
Indians during the pandemic.
The fact is that India has over the years
converted itself into a
powerhouse of vaccine creation.
In fact, more than half
of the world's children are inoculated
with a vaccine developed in India.
And therefore this one particular company
the Serum Institute of India
which is situated just
outside Mumbai was seen
as a hope for the world, not just India.
Adar Poonawalla is the head
the CEO of the Serum Institute of India.
And he's this 40-year-old son
of a billionaire father
who founded this company
in the 1960s.
In mid-2020, Poonawalla signed a deal
with AstraZeneca to supply one billion doses
of its vaccine for the world
and 400 million of those
were meant to be produced
by the end of the year.
Now that didn't really play
out as things went ahead.
By January, it transpired
that only 70 million
of those doses have been produced so far
and in the start of January, there
wasn't a huge amount of demand in India
because basically there
weren't that many cases
and all the while India's
government was sending tens
of millions of doses out overseas,
it was engaged in COVID vaccine diplomacy.
It was really trying
to sort of needle China
which was attempting to do
the same at the time as well.
India has exported or donated
more than 60 million doses
of coronavirus vaccines to
countries far poorer than India.
It was seen as a massive
diplomatic victory
for India's ruling party.
Little did they know
that a more potent strain
of the virus was
at the same time brewing
within the people in India.
So there were various
consequences of India emerging
relatively unscathed from the first wave.
One of those was the sense
to be self-sufficient.
Prime Minister Modi imposed massive taxes
on imported goods.
Unfortunately, some
of these goods that were imported
was stuff that's essential
for our scientists,
labs to test the virus.
The second mistake that
was made was the calling
for elections and not just elections
but massive public rallies.
Some of them led by Prime
Minister Modi himself.
The next rung of mistakes
that were made was
giving the green light for
massive religious ceremonies.
A sure shot recipe for a super-spreader.
The next problem that
local authorities point
out is over-centralization of powers
within the Prime Minister's office
including how oxygen will be
shared between the states.
This really has proved
to be a game changer
because every time a
state fell short of oxygen
it lacked the powers to go
out and get it for themselves.
One of the scariest things
when the second wave hit was the fact
that India was running out of oxygen.
I visited a private
hospital in New Delhi where
they didn't know from
one day to the next, how
much oxygen they were going to receive,
when it would come and
how long it would last.
And they had dozens of patients
on oxygen and relying on
that oxygen to stay alive.
Oh, I get maybe around 50 calls every day.
Somebody that's asking for bed,
somebody asking for cylinders,
somebody asking for drugs.
We don't have anything available
and patients are dying.
Now, India produces more
oxygen than it needs.
The problem is that most
of it is produced in the
eastern part of the country
which lacks supply links
to the rest of the country.
On a typical day, when it's
business as usual in India
hospitals will place a standing order.
But when a situation breaks
down the way it did with the panic
of the second wave, supply
chains completely get eradicated
and that is what India saw.
What this led to is it
led to black marketing.
The hospitals had certain
contractual agreements
with oxygen suppliers,
but there are always
people willing to pay more for that.
As a consequence, we are
in this terrible humanitarian
disaster, really,
where people the citizens
of India have had to plead
for oxygen on Twitter.
It was an unprecedented situation, really,
in India that so many
so-called privileged people
found themselves suddenly
in the same boat, as very average Indians
all fighting for that
one oxygen concentrator
or that one last hospital bed
that one particular hospital had going.
And it was really a free-for-all.
While people are looking at social media
hoping to find that lifeline
oftentimes social media has
actually increased the trauma
for families of patients
because they end up
calling dozens and dozens of numbers
and then find that, you know,
they've lost precious time.
And there have been instances that I know
of where patients have passed away
because the network
hasn't quite come through.
The asymmetry, I think has
been particularly stark
during this crisis that
people who don't have access
to the internet or don't
have a smartphone that they
where they can WhatsApp
somebody to ask for something,
then they've been kind of really left out
of this whole fight for resources.
They don't even get a chance.
What we were seeing is
people lying in beds.
People being bundled
into any possible vehicle
that was available
because ambulances were in short supply
and being taken to hospital
for just that instant hit
of oxygen that could
possibly prolong their life.
What we saw was heart-rending
messages on WhatsApp
where families were
telling other relatives
or their friends, my loved one has died
which means that the hospital
now has a bed available,
you can take it.
What we saw was reporters going
out on the field, going out
to crematoriums and
saying that the government
has told us 40 people
died in the city today.
I am showing you, my camera is showing you
that 500 pyres are burning right now.
What we had was crematorium
workers telling us
I will go to hell if I lie to you
and tell you that this is
not as bad as it sounds.
We went to one of the main
crematoriums on the outskirts
of Delhi, which is on the
banks of the Ganges River.
There was so many pyres burning.
The heat was extraordinary
and of course, instead of
the normal mourning scenes
that you would have,
all of the relatives are
in full PPE and no one can hear each other
through the masks and over the
sound of the fires burning.
It's traumatic enough to have
someone that you love die
but to have to not be able to save them
and to try so hard to do it
is just absolutely agonizing.
So when people started asking
for vaccines urgently,
India just did not have
the supply to give them.
The country of 1.3 billion
people which had so generously
donated vaccines to countries,
far poorer than itself
earlier, suddenly found
that their own population
was effectively naked.
It lacked the protection
that even a single dose
of the coronavirus vaccine could offer.
That's a big irony is that
you've got the world's
largest vaccine producing hub
but it isn't able to supply itself
let alone the rest of the world.
So many of the poor
and middle income countries
that were dependent on India
supplying the COVAX Initiative,
for instance, that's just not
going to happen for a while.
They're really,
those countries are the
ones that are going to
be very hard hit by this.
And at the same time, you know
I think a lot of Western
countries have been criticized
for not sharing their vaccines
particularly with India
and others as well.
So you're really seeing
this as a, you know
kind of part of the picture
of the wider sort of
global inequality that we're
seeing around around vaccines.
Some of the poorest
and the most vulnerable
sections of society probably
lack even the basic health infrastructure
that is a human requirement,
it's a basic right, but
probably for the first time
the so-called privileged
in this country are
facing what the poor
Indian faces every day.
That not even money can
buy you a hospital bed
and really the second wave
of the coronavirus has
exposed severe cracks
in Indian society and
Indian policymaking in
India's healthcare system that
are essential to be filled
if we have to go ahead as a nation.
When cases started shooting up
and there were thousands
of fatalities, a lot
of people on the social, on
social media networks called
for Prime Minister Modi's resignation.
And then the next thing you heard was
that the government had asked Facebook
and Twitter to take down those posts.
But there were also
instances where social media
networks just took down
these hashtags on their own
and then came in for a huge criticism
because they were acting
really out of turn
because they were actually
stifling people's criticism
of the government and
of the prime minister
in handling this massive tragedy.
This has been the single biggest failure
of the union government
in the last 73 years
and 73 years is since the
independence of India.
So we can see the political
impact, the political impact
of Modi's popularity being eroded probably
for the first time as people die
as people realize that privilege
no longer protects you.
Prime Minister Modi was elected
on a massive majority in 2014
and he repeated that in 2019,
he came in on a very
business friendly platform
and he has made some
considerable reforms in India
like a momentous decision in 2016
to demonetize part of the currency
and basically ban 86% of
the currency overnight.
And it didn't seem to affect
his popularity at all.
So he's used to being the
leader of the country that
that talks to people about
really big picture issues and
and almost on, on a religious level.
So I think he thought he
could float above COVID
but the fact that no family
in India has been
untouched by this epidemic.
Everybody knows somebody who's
who's sick or who's died.
You know, there's no way
that the government can hide
from the impact of this virus.
And as, as one analyst said to us
you can explain away bad GDP numbers
but you can't explain
away a dead family member.
That's not something that
the government is going to
be able to cover up.
It's unclear yet though,
whether his support has really
been dented in the long
term, elections are still
years away.
So it's really yet to be seen
if this is a turning point
in Modi's support and
his political narrative
whether he can come back from this.
B.1.617, the variant of
the novel Coronavirus,
first sequenced in India is
fast-spreading across the world.
If Indians are not vaccinated
quickly, if India doesn't
do everything to contain
its spread quickly enough,
the risk is that more and
more of these mutations
could threaten not just
the health and livelihoods
of the rest of the world,
but also immense economic supply chains.
India contributes more than
8% to global growth, but
if you integrate what
India does into the systems
of the world, into large banks,
into large pharmaceutical companies, most
of the seafaring ships, which
haul cargo from one country
to the other, most of these
ships are manned by Indians.
What will happen to the
supply chains around the world
if Indians are unable to get
up, get out of their beds,
go to work, be healthy,
think, be on their feet,
enable that business continues as usual?
As India's power and stature has grown
over the years, as it has taken
on more and more leadership
roles on the global stage.
World powers in particular,
the U.S. is very reliant
on India as providing a kind
of buffer against the rise
of China in particular, in the Asian region.
It's really important that
as a democratic country
on the border with China
India maintains a strong global role
and if it's unable to get
this pandemic under control
if it's unable to boost
its health infrastructure
enough to create a stable
environment and therefore
allow its economy to recover from the lockdowns,
then that global stature that India
has, will be under threat.
It's a lesson, not just
for policymakers in India.
It's a lesson for leaders everywhere
about the areas of
policymaking that need focus.
About what could go wrong
with just one single decision.
That a tiny virus, unseen
by the naked eye can take
down strong men all over the world,
if they're not careful.